bonjour et léo norvège merci beaucoup
d'être en direct avec nous ce matin sur
rtl france david roth va bientôt nous
rejoindre
on est en train de se connecter merci en
tout cas de votre présence pour débattre
de ce thème de l'insécurité un enjeu
majeur important pour 2022 alors que
l'actualité est encore très marquée par
ces faits divers hier un jeune homme qui
a bousculé sa professeur a été condamné
à cinq mois de prison avec sursis on va
voir les images à l'écran d'ailleurs
votre réaction à cette peine est ce
qu'elle est à la hauteur des faits
commises selon vous
mais non ça c'est ans explique mans avec
oak et je sais pas je pense qu'il doit
être mineure mais c'est extrêmement
grave d'agresser son professeur ça monte
ça monte aujourd'hui qu' il n'y a plus
aucune aucun respect pour l'état pour la
république aux localités pour rien il ya
des risques et total en france mais pour
vous c'est un fait isolé on trouve c'est
aussi ça montre une tendance dans
l'éducation nationale par ses dons parce
qu'on en voit régulièrement aussi sûr il
suffit d'aller sur les réseaux sociaux
sur twitter etc on va régulièrement
maintenant c'est faute aux agressions de
professeurs alors à plusieurs niveaux
j'ai été très choqué aussi par
l'agression de ce jeune homme
car j'entends dire que la sécurité c'est
pas une priorité à l'agression que ce
jeune homme à montgeron
parce qu'il a une orientation
sexuelle différente je dire il ya ça il
ya les professeurs il ya la police il
s'était c'est un ensemble maintenant de
faits d'insécurité a viré et surtout du
respect pour la république dit respect
pour l'état parce que quoi parce que
derrière en fait je pense tout
simplement qu'il ya un tel laxisme en
fait ils se disent ils font ça en toute
impunité donc aujourd'hui avant j'allais
dire à mon époque où évidemment on ne
voyait absolument pas ça sur les
professeurs étaient pas question de
frapper son plus récent
aujourd'hui c'est normal pour une pour
une note pour un regard et pour quoi que
ce soit donc c'est très grave parce que
ça ses enseignants arrivé dans des
établissements où mêmes ne se sentent
plus en sécurité enfin c'est un cercle
vicieux qui est extrêmement
préoccupante extrêmement inquiétant
drogba serait david ross est avec nous
et david rose est ce que vous avez
entendu le début de cette intervention
d'eléonore belle on parlait de ce
professeur qui a été agressé dans son
dans son lycée
l'adolescent et écope d'une peine de
cinq mois de prison avec sursis est ce
que cette peine est à la hauteur de
l'acte commis selon vous
donc bonjour à tous j'ai effectivement
suivi dès le début de cette matinale
d'abord je rejoins tout à fait le
diagnostic on voit qu'on a une société
qui est de plus en plus violente qui se
manifeste à l'école mais pas que est ce
qu'on a vu et intolérable l'or s'est
amplifiée par le fait que vous avez
maintenant les normands de réseaux
sociaux donc moi ce qui m'a choqué au
delà de la grille soit une main la vidéo
que des jeunes que ça les mettre sur les
réseaux et même certains en rigole donc
on voit bien que globalement
effectivement il ya une non prise de
conscience de cette violence et la
gravité de ces violences quand on la
condamne à huy tard la castration si
j'ai une décision de la justice donc
effectivement il est mineur donc un
direct ce qui est important c'est
qu'elle arrive très très vite pour qu'on
puisse en parler plus important 6 avait
traité un an
autre fait préoccupant comment est-ce
qu'un élève tout simplement filmé en
plein cours avec son téléphone portable
voyez ce qu'on a dit georges kuzmanovic
il est répudiée les présidents de
républiques souveraines également
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
regarder
total soutien à l'enseignante de
combs-la-ville stop à l' angoisse des
enseignants qui ne peuvent plus faire
leur travail honte à ceux qui ont filmé
ce crime président j'ai instauré un
retour à la discipline et l'uniforme à
l'école les téléphones seront laissés à
l'entrée très cette question des
téléphones c'est une mesure simple hein
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'est pas tout
simplement l'interdiction en place david
ross alors d'abord c'est tout à fait
possible un mois je suis conseiller
départemental il ya des collèges ou le
règlement intérieur interdit la présence
du téléphone dans les lycées
généralement une souplesse qui donnait
un petit peu plus forte mais si tout à
fait aussi possible de les interdire
après il faut regarder les deux aspects
serre que quand vous avez un jeune qui
quittent l'établissement il faut qu'ils
aient aussi son téléphone s'ils un
trajet long qu'il a besoin aussi de
pouvoir joindre le cas échéant ses
parents donc là qui sont qu'il peut se
poser si si l'apa le téléphone ou est-ce
qu'il est mignon qu'il faut on en rit
ensuite au personnel est ce qui est du
personnel à l'entrée qui vérifie ça qui
récupère le téléphone mais effectivement
pendant la journée cours on n'a pas
besoin de son téléphone alors comment
garantir la sécurité des professeurs la
question se pose évidemment énorme
baisse puisqu'on est bien bientôt à
l'anniversaire de l'hommage pour samuel
pâtit qui je le rappelle a été décapité
par un islamiste à conflans sainte
honorine comment garantir la sécurité
des professeurs va parler de la sécurité
des citoyens après
vous savez garantir la garantir la
sécurité des professeurs
l'agent tenté sur l'histoire du
téléphone etc bon combs-la-ville cesser
son délit c'est souvent dans lesquelles
ça se passe qui sont assez sensibles
et qui est le problème en fait si vous
voulez n'ai jamais traité de
l'insécurité et la sécurité car autour
il ya des endroits des délices et dans
la creuse ou des lycées à marseille dans
des beaux quartiers où les gens peuvent
avoir des téléphones et ne pas agresser
leurs professeurs malheureusement c'est
le fait aussi de certains individus qui
sont souvent issus de ces quartiers
qu'on a arrosé d'argent
et qui aujourd'hui se permettent tout et
n'importe quoi parce que le laxisme
judiciaire est telle qu'ils savent que
de toute façon ils n'iront pas en prison
et que de toute façon ils sont libres en
totale impunité donc ça c'est une
première chose et je crois qu'avec
pour marine le pen an en 2020 a publié
un livre blanc sur la sécurité avec des
mesures très claires et un constat un
constat très clair qui je crois est et
celui la lys
la justice la réponse pénale doit être
absolument à la hauteur de ces
agressions quant à l'assassinât de sa
mère pattie à cette horreur
j'allais dire que cette monstruosité qui
est arrivé sur notre territoire c'est
bien le fait que ce n'est pas un
problème de sécurité nichols et apam de
sécurité nationale un problème de
sécurité du fait qu'on laisse rentrer
des islamistes sur le territoire
français on laisse prospérer l'islamisme
sur le territoire français et comme le
disait très justement d'ailleurs un
monsieur vous un tien
interrogé dans le premier reportage on
les connaît voilà les renseignements
généraux la sécurité intérieure connaît
ces islamistes on connaît en fait ces
réseaux on connaît ces filières est la
meilleure réponse c'est évidemment de
l'église
de les mettre hors d'état de nuire et de
les expulser on ne peut pas laisser
aujourd'hui au nombre au nom de
de l'islamiste d'une théorie extrémistes
des voiliers
assassiné massacre et décapité un
professeur ça c'est absolument de franck
depuis un an on aurait dû prendre la
mesure de ce qui a été avec les
attentats et avec sa mère pattie on
aurait dû prendre la mesure de la
sécurité de cette insécurité causés par
les islamistes une insécurité
gravissime et aujourd'hui ce n'est
toujours pas pour protéger les
établissements scolaires valérie
pécresse a mis en place en ile de france
des brigades régionales de sécurité
qu'en pensez vous david ross est ce que
est ce que c'est suffisant à marseille
d'ailleurs il ya même des retraités qui
se mobilisent aux abords des
établissements scolaires pour garantir
un minimum de sécurité est ce que ça
marche d'abord effectivement j'ai une
pensée pour les proches et la famille de
samuel paquet puisque aujourd'hui dans
mon lycée d'orsay il y aura notamment
une 2e minute de silence qui sera
observé à l'ensemble des élèves et
personnels de l'établissement alors
effectivement en ile de france il ya eu
un certain nombre de moyens qui ont été
mis par rapport ce que j'appelle les
abords des lycées donc c'est un élément
important il peut y avoir des endroits
où on sait qu'à du trafic on sait que
des jeunes sont attendus et des jeunes
repères voilà donc pu y avoir des
brigades guy au lycée mais il en va
surtout la coordination des forces de
l'ordre entre la police nationale et la
police municipale
lorsqu'il ya quelques faits avérés non
mais les dispositions en place en
coordonnant tous des acteurs donc ça
c'est important tirez pas de ces gadgets
mais bon des moyens supplémentaires
c'est pas la région d'assurer cette
sécurité a priori non tout à fait mais
c'est pas non plus à la police
municipale d'intervenir normalement donc
voilà mes leçons n'en parlera peut-être
les moyens faut le dire du moins la
police actuellement sont pas à la
hauteur des enjeux puisque l'on vit dans
notre société donc nous acteurs locaux
ben on agit avec les moyens dont on
dispose et évidemment on va pas même si
on demande des moyens supplémentaires à
l'état dans la période on va pas juste 7
spectateurs et donc on essaie d'agir
donc la région et c'est agir à son
niveau les villes sites agir un niveau
du leur mais tout ça c'est la sécurité
juste à l'entrée
et donc il faut qu'il y ait un travail
qui soit complet qui soit à l'entrée du
lycée qui soit dans le lycée
et surtout et moi j'insiste là dessus
qu'ils soient en amont de la présence
des jeunes dans le lycée il faut qu'avec
les services jeunesse il y ait une
attention particulière parce qu'on
reperd des jeunes on repère des familles
on sait qu'elles sont en difficulté et
donc il faut qu'un accompagnement de
prévention si on veut éviter de gérer de
plein fouet cette violence est-ce qu'il
faut des centres d'éducation pour pour
les jeunes comme le préconise aussi
valérie pécresse
alors après ça dépend des situations là
encore on peut à l'envi décliner plein
de choses qu on proposerait reste à la
fin la confrontation qui est moyen et la
réalité du terrain donc moi je pense
qu'il faut que ces lisent ces
établissements dehors du temps scolaire
soit aussi des lieux ouverts des lieux
d'éducation des lieux d'insertion et
peut y avoir une forme ultime de centres
de rééducation mais juste en sortir un
parent parce qu'il est violent vous
risquez d'en sortir beaucoup du système
donc le constat il est tellement
importante sur cette perte de repères
sur l'ordre sur l'éducation qu'il faut
revoir le système éducatif il faut pas
dire j'en sors quelques uns et je les
enferme dans des prisons pour jeunes je
pas sûr que ce soit la solution eléonore
baez à la veille du déplacement des
manuels macron à marseille cette
déclaration la préfet des
bouches-du-rhône a fait hurler les
policiers très en colère regardez sa
déclaration on en parle après
évidemment parfois il ya des actes de
violence et il y en a eu quelques uns
ces derniers jours dans les cités
marseillette à l'encontre des policiers
est ce que je vois ce sont des policiers
courageux qui n'hésite pas dans ces
cas-là à revenir à chaque fois à refaire
leur mission à l'interpeller les
trafiquants les déférer devant la
justice pour qu'ils répondent de leurs
actes il n'y a pas de zone de non droit
à marseille il n'y a pas de zone de non
droit les policiers affirment le
contraire sans penserez vous
m'écoutez moi je soutiens je serai
toujours du côté de l'ordre et de la
police qui a qui connaît ces zones de
non droit qui a beaucoup de mal à y
rentrer parce qu'ils sont trop peu
nombreux en effectif face à
au déferlement de deux dealers qui lia
qui ne se cache même pas dans les cités
marseillaises où effectivement quand
vous rentrez dans une cité on vous
demande
j'ai dit ça encore une fois j'habite à
côté donc c'est pas c'est pas
compliqué on vous demande en fait où
vous allez voilà vous avez des gardiens
à l'entrée des sites et parce que il
faut pas déranger le point de le point
de vente le points de deal alors le film
back nord n'est pas du tout on n'est pas
du tout une fiction c'est une réalité à
marseille où vous avez d'ailleurs il ya
un exemple sur les le collège le collège
henri barnier voiliers qui est juste en
face de la castellane qui est une cité
un haut lieu du trafic et vous avez des
élèves et bien qu'ils vont directement
entre midi et deux aller faire les choux
fin donc aller regarder les points de
deal ils ont 11 12 ans et ils sont là
tranquillement il n'y a pas du tout de
si vous voulez ça a l'air de faire
partie d ça fait partie des moeurs
désormais dans les lancers quartier ces
quartiers prioritaires politique de la
ville dont je rappelle qu'on a arrosé
d'argent très largement depuis 40 ans
qui lie à tous les centres sociaux
possible toutes les crèches tout il ya
même des piscines il ya même des
équipements sportifs partout donc il
n'ya pas de
raison il n'y aurait pas de raison a
priori qu'il y ait autant de trafic et
vous avez des points de vente qui ceux
qui se montrent tous les to les taux
pratiquement tous les dix mètres donc
effectivement il y à des zones de non
droit à marseille il ya des zones où en
tant que femme vous ne pouvez pas rendre
créée il ya des zones où même en tant
qu'homme on ne peut pas rentrer il ya
des hommes où la police a du mal à
rentrer parce qu'elle est passée elle
n'a pas assez de moyens et derrière
surtout les policiers arrêtent ces
dealers ça va arrêter sa faire leur
travail
sont parfaitement et le font avec
courage dans ces endroits mais surtout
derrière il n'ya pas la réponse
judiciaire quand un policier va arrêter
quand vous allez arrêter un dealer vous
allez arrêter d chouf vous allez arrêter
un des trafiquants des gens qui sont qui
tient l'est ces
réseaux est qui et qui tiennent
d'ailleurs des quartiers entiers par
l'argent de ces réseaux parce que ça
rapporte énormément tant que derrière il
n'ya pas la réponse ni politique ni
judiciaire ray adapté qui serait
effectivement les peines de prison
l'arrêt des à des
questions familiales pour les familles
et bien à ce moment là il ne peut pas y
avoir de sécurité ce cercle là ne peut
pas s'arrêter d'avis dans la société
je vous avez beaucoup parlé aux normes
nous reste peu de temps donc j'aurai
quand même avoir le sentiment de david
ross là dessus sur sur ces fameuses
zones de non droit où les policiers ne
peuvent plus aller j'imagine que dans
l'essonne il y à aussi ce type de
problème et c'est une c'est un manque de
moyens ou alors c'est tellement que
d'une politique d'un courage politique
pour pouvoir faire en sorte que les
policiers agissent
je dirais les deux d'abord madame la
préfète dans sa phrase a dû se tromper
devers elle a dû vouloir dire il ne peut
pas y avoir de zone de non droit la
réalité elle est tout ce que je disais
aussi tout à l'heure sur la situation
dans certains lycées et donc là encore
il faut que la volonté politique
d'évoquer les moyens nécessaires et de
les donner et quand on les donne
forcément c'est les choix budgétaires
donc ça peut ne pas plaire à certains
mais la réalité c'est que les policiers
sont prêts à intervenir ils sont prêts à
aller dans ces zones identifiées mais il
faut leur en donner les moyens ils vont
pas aller à 3 contre 350 organisée donc
il faut qu'ils mobilisation de
l'ensemble des forces de l'ordre sur ces
questions là et elles sont connues sont
connus donc effectivement une vraie
volonté permettrait n'ont pas de réseau
du jour au lendemain parce qu'il faut
pas être non plus naïfs et et bisounours
c'est quelque chose qui a ancré dans
certains quartiers en profondeur avec
des des chaînes des populations qui sont
utilisés depuis première h faut dire
aussi donc ça demande un vrai travail ça
demande aussi un travail alternatifs une
fois encore éducatif messi à la volonté
à tout à fait la possibilité
de s'occuper de cette chose-là votre
réaction dans l'essonne puisqu'il ya eu
ces tags aussi à l'encontre de policiers
et de leur famille avec des noms qui ont
été inscrits l'anonyme l'anonymisation
des policiers c'est une solution
s'arrête ça va compliquer le problème
non
oui alors d'abord ces tags sont la
manifestation ce que je disais gagne
violence qu'on a vu au début sur sur
l'extrait que nous avions montré mais la
violence elle est surtout verbale moi je
sens chez les jeunes et de tous milieux
vous dire les choses clairement de tous
milieux je sens chez les jeunes nous des
mots qui est extrêmement violent dans
les propos qui ensuite peuvent
effectivement traduire un passage à
l'acte et donc il faut aussi pour ça je
reviens sur le l'ensemble de la chine
agir sur le système éducatif et dès le
premier âge sur des mots mal utilisé sur
la violence verbale il faut que les
l'éducation à sol mais aussi les
familles les parents aient conscience de
ça et interviennent donc voilà donc
après les policiers c'est anonymisées
moi je veux bien mais sur le terrain les
policiers quand ils vont dans les
quartiers sont connus souvent d'ailleurs
c'est important qu'ils cette police de
proximité
parce que tous les jeunes ne sont pas
des délinquants en revanche tous les
jeunes à un moment sont confrontés à des
tentations et donc s'il ya ce rapport
humain aussi avec les policiers c'est
plus sain la difficulté c'est pas tant
le nom c'est de connaître le lieu où ils
habitent ces deux voix lasse et de la
proximité peut être aussi elle est
nécessaire mais peut être aussi gênant
pour la vie des policiers et pour leur
propre famille merci beaucoup il ne
reste plus de temps malheureusement
merci d'avoir participé à ce débat en
direct sur rt france merci à tous les
deux